the Leafs will get a change quick up ahead
and Alex tuck will regroup It Center on to
the right side power nice pass tuck in
and a locker stop there by W swung back
to kingberg one more try KNE Lander will pass
off now hold on take a long look touch pass it
front off the post and the rebound cleared
off sight there but down low quick movement
off the and Levi with one good save but the
post helped him on that one in tight second
unit comes on doy's got it he'll pass it down
for twoy and R it as Levi again off yard tro
on the door step said when you're playing
with neander that that combination has just
been deadly early on he did say he doesn't
follow that list here to break B marter in
scores
[Applause] six game point streak for martyr and
goals in back to back every single zone Buffalo
Savers Top Line thinking offense they get a puck
to the point but they get it turned over and how
about that pass right through the slot tape to
tape as ym Mar puts it exactly without losing
a stride Marner now in all alone no hesitation
just KCK backhand for and you can see that Deon
Levi is fairly deep he's starting to slide back
overextend your shift there on the power play so
a quick change power sends it across he gets
it back from PKA big going and power takes a
look onetime and olon missed the target 28 goal
scor last year they'll reset and it's PKA firing
scores power play goal and buffalo has tied
it as well that's a five-game streak for him
three goals now in that stretch but this is just
simple power play tactics look at the positioning
moso in front wall takes a look around his
left and you got to make a decision as a
goenda and the initial Peak left
there by wall that's when the shot
happened pass on to the left side off the ski
to Matthews and Gerson goes to work here's zus
Gerson off wall in front Jo shot stop back
to the point and that blast just missed the
target Le went another face off tarus behind the
net tapped Away by power up the boards power and
crbs the assists on the goal and here's a two
on1 Thomson in stops and that glanced off the
goal post I believe and out to play Matthews back
door Kingbird for neander down low across there's
the back door play and Le by a brilliant stop and
the puck fired down the ice another aggressive
move there by Tavaris down right by the blue paint
but he just like the calmness of Deon Levi there
he didn't overreact so he kept the stick on
the ice and tarus couldn't find anything Tage
tops of bricks it up he's got to break Thompson in
stop and scores shorthanded rebound goal and Tes
Thompson who couldn't beat wol on the power play
does short hit there was no option in he took a
quick look to know it now you've got the last two
guys that cannot turn the puck over and this one
just trickles through as you see Joseph's Wall's
frustration he felt that it was behind him and
actually knocked it in himself wasn't able to get
to it quick enough quick backhand forehand went
underneath the arm look at how aggressively the
Buffalo Savers are attacking in the zone they're
not allowing any easy neutral zone open ice
and trying to stand up at the line they slide
through though Here Comes elander in the slot
Matthews scores on the rush power play goal game
tied over no speed by Matthews and Marner this
time the aggressiveness everybody staying up
over the line and it's Marner who sifts his
way through two Buffalo Sabers that opens
up the middle of the ice and Matthews comes
jumping in through on cck and you give him
that kind of opportunity right down the
middle number 34 is going to score more
than not neander with a perfect pass and yet
another point B Mar's got a couple of points
to the game and it's two2 here comes legon
with Greer driving to the net Puck doesn't
arrive and back out comes Buffalo lead te
skinners in shn SC Jeff Skinner answers right
back and Ryan Johnson gets his first point he's
the one who makes that pass and the fourth line
for the Leafs gets a chance chance but how about
Johnson not only getting past reees but making
a perfect pass in stride to Skinner and Skinner
just puts his head down here in just a wonderfully
place up and over the shoulder Leafs have had
a couple of third period comebacks this year
in fact from two goals down against monreal and
Tampa trying to W back here and they have Austin
Matthew new has the leak leaded goals and the
leaps have tied it 17 seconds in the attention
to details and play with a purpose this is a
play that is a tie draw and it's in on the for
check yro gets it in first Mar goes in on the
for check the de man pinches to come down and
keep the pressure on and you see this so often 16
finding 34 this will be an interesting period and
a really important one for the Buffalo Sabers too
and the three games in four nights you think if
they can ratchet it up a notch here having played
the intense that they have here's a chance in
front and big stop rebound scores Jordan Greenway
and again Buffalo takes the lead that created the
scoring chance here's a four check Greenway keeps
it alive along the board PKA tries to get it out
in front and what a first save there by wall
but on the rebound PKA with a nice pass that
goes off the Stick of Marner but now kingberg is
tight to his net and Greenway just Matthews fires
that Faceoff win right back jump scored tipped in
front it's a hatrick for Austin [Music] [Applause]
Matthews I'm not sure all the fans know that
he got a piece of it there's only one hat on
the ice right now on Thursday in the face off
dot you had one from Center Ice that ends up
in the back and there's the next right through
jordano getting that making sure that puck gets
through and there's a double deflection both he
and clion in front got a piece of it but jordano
makes sure he gets it past John tarus off the
boards to jordano who threw the assist on the
last Matthews goal KN Lander fired that is blocked
and it's a clearcut breakway the other way it's
JJ PKA stopped darene plays it in behind the net
Skinner trying to S her tops it at the side of the
cage and the Sabers keep applying pressure flip
them across toen scorge hits somebody in front
and it's Alex tuck oh started from the corner and
this is a shot from Rasmus denene but right off
the arm look at the reaction to tuck just just
laughing here you know there's times when you
make a great play and you got no chance and now
on to the Stick of nander neander holds on takes
a long one gives it to kingberg shooting and
knocked down in front neander trying to stop it
up Alex tucks away empty net and Tuck is going to
score again and it's six4 Savers first though now
you get it alive but this is a play that you
just can't make if you're John Clan but it's
just far too casual a rer right into the Bread
Basket that gets blocked round it comes to petka
the clock drains a big road win Buffalo gets back
to 500 and six and six and the least fall to 542